Oh my.
Alhamdulillah.
Tonight,
[Silence]
as per usual, Saturday night, we have
our weekly question and answer session.
And as usual, we usually begin this half
an hour. May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
accept it and make it blessed. A blessed
transfer of knowledge and inheritance
from our prophet sallall.aii wasallam to
our hearts.
We usually begin with a small reminder,
something to kind of get the juices
flowing.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
he tells us to remind one another to
remind why because the reminder is of
benefit and consequence for the
believers. Many of us we have a lot more
knowledge than we probably
give ourselves credit for in the sense
that throughout our years most of us
especially born as Muslims grew up in a
Muslim household we've heard a lot of
commonplace narrations verses a lot of
things that are very well known and
common place in our religion.
However, years and years go by and the
sharpness of these things starts to dull
in our minds. This is why it is so
important to constantly read the Quran
over and over and over. Never a person's
journey with the Quran never stops
over and over and over. Every time they
finish it, they turn it over and read it
again. As a matter of fact, some
scholars would advise that a person
never leave on the exact end of the
Quran. They would restart it before they
end their final sitting of the evening
or the day with it. Why? So that it is
in a constant loop. And the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam commanded
that we
recite the Quran at least once a month.
At least once a month.
And
alkari and Muslim the prophet
sallallah.aihi Wasam.
It was brought to his attention that one
of his most devout
companions and the scholars of the
companions.
He had just gotten married. But when his
father went to visit him, he found that
his wife was muted.
and she wasn't dressed nice. She didn't
look she was you know was taking
care of herself. And usually this
articulates a problem in the household.
Why? Because naturally a woman will
want to you know grab the attention
or catch the eye of her husband and vice
versa. And so he asked her what the
issue is and she told him that Abdullah
is one of the best men as a slave to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
But he has no use for marriage or women.
The guy is constantly fasting. He was
praying all night every night. So he'd
never sleep next to her. He is fasting
every single day and he is reading the
Quran every day once a day the whole
Quran.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam commanded him to
lessen of that
and the most he allowed him to fast
every day is how much? Anyone know the
narration?
What is the maximum allowance for
fasting for a person?
How much?
Very good. Which is fasting one day,
breaking your fast the other. So every
other day and the most a person
can pray in the night is the same
narration. The prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam mentioned the of of and that a
person should sleep a part of the night
and pray a part of the night. And in
commanding him to recite the Quran, he
said read it once a month, once every 30
days. In some wordings of this
narration, once every 40 days. He said,
He said, "I can do better than that. I
can do more than that."
He said then once every
10 days and he continued to go down
14 days, 10 days, 7 days, once a week
until he said sai wasam that the most is
that once every 3 days and anything
faster than once every 3 days, a person
is generally unable to unable to be
consistent with that and second of all
unable to contemplate the Quran properly
because now they're in too much of a
hurry trying to finish its recitation.
So some of the scholars of Islam derived
from this narration and took from this
narration that a Muslim who is able to
read the Quran
has no excuse to not read it at least
once a month once every 30 days should
complete the mus the Quran.
And if a person doesn't have the ability
to do so then they should learn. There's
nothing stopping a person today, whether
they're blind or even if they're deaf,
from learning the recitation of the
Quran. We've got entire mah in braille.
Now,
literacy is at an all-time high
worldwide. There's no reason a person
cannot learn to recite the book of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and give it of his
time. However, person should not be
extreme in anything that he or she does
and part of that is the recitation of
the Quran. Person does not push himself
until he burns out nor does he ignore
the Quran until he forgets it. Now, so
having said that, inshallah we will
start with any questions.
Now guys, if you don't have a question
for me, I'm gonna ask you a question.
And that's the one that's
[Arabic recitation]
Anyone has a question?
Okay, I I'll start.
[Arabic recitation]
talk you gave last Thursday when you
were talking about the taps of
so the question I have is follow up
to what Abu J asked which is that in
this generation we have less scholars
than previous generations and you said
it was a prophecy from prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. but also
you suggested that we can kind of fix
that by having our each of the each
family will send their best ch child
to to become a scholar.
[Arabic recitation]
prophecy and also the possibility of
kind of fixing that by sending children
to become scholars.
Yeah, the prophecy is not every prophecy
is a prohibition. This is a very
important point. Not every prophecy is a
prohibition and not every prophecy is a
command. What does that mean?
Is it that every single time the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam gives a prophecy
of the day of judgment? for
instance, he says one of the signs of
the day of judgment or the day of
judgment will not come until such and
such happens. Is that always a dis a
dispraise of that thing? No, not
necessarily.
For instance, one of the things that is
prophesized is
widespread literacy. This is something
that's going to happen
which the scholars have told us is the
modern vehicle. He prophesies that the
vehicle and things vehicles and
literacy and airplanes which are found
in narrations. Are these all
dispraised? The answer is no. These are
not necessarily dispraised and vice
versa. Not everything that is a prophecy
is necessarily a command. So not
everything that is prophesized is
necessarily a prohibition. Nor is
everything that is prophesized
necessarily a command to do or be
something. When we see that the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
prophesized
that ignorance would become widespread.
That in itself
is not a command nor a prohibition.
Rather we take the prohibition of
ignorance, ignorance in our religion
from other sources. So when we see
prophecies that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam tells us that the end of
time people will have access to
information no other time but
simultaneously there will be widespread
ignorance no other time. This
doesn't mean that we shouldn't try to
correct that and it doesn't necessarily
mean that we can particularly avoid
that. Why is he telling us this? He's
telling us this for a number of reasons.
Number one, so that we can try to push
that off as far and as much as possible.
Number two, so that we can correct it.
Number three, so that we can expect it.
And a person doesn't start to feel
despondent, melancholy, and
you know hopeless when they see these
things. They see for instance widespread
ignorance and they say, "Wow, I never
thought that the of Muhammad would
ever be this. I never thought
things would be this." And start to
have doubt in their heart. However, when
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us there a time is going to come
when these things will happen. This is
all part of what? Part of the decree of
Allah. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does
whatever he wants.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. We do not base our
actions around what Allah does or
doesn't do or is or is not going to
choose to do. We base our actions on
what Allah has commanded us to do and we
try to never become sidetracked with
what Allah is doing and forget what we
are supposed to be doing. That's what
happened on the day of correct. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us the story
of they became sidetracked with what
Allah is doing and forgot about what
Allah has commanded them to do. And this
spelled destruction and failure. And so
the point here is that widespread
ignorance and especially amongst the
Muslims, especially with regards to
their own religion is something that we
will fight against until the end of time
with the last and final of our breath.
But Allah does what he chooses.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. And if he chooses
to allow our efforts to be fruitful at
any given time, then alhamdulillah. And
if he chooses any given time for our
efforts not to be fruitful, then that is
his discretion. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
second of all, when we look at the
decree of Allah, the decree of Allah,
how do we know for sure when something
is the decree of Allah?
That's that's a real question I'm
asking. How do we know for sure that
something
is the decree of Allah?
[Arabic recitation]
Think about it. when we say Allah
decreed this, Allah wrote this.
This is written to happen. How do we
know that that's going to that that is
part of Allah's decree of Allah's?
How do we know
when it h very good? Who said that?
Look at that. We've got our own
theologian here, our homegrown
theologian, mashallah, hiding in the
cut. Now the only way for us to know
something is the decree of Allah
is either Allah tells us Quran and
Sunnah or it happens and it becomes
passed. There's no other way.
Right? This is why we are taught that
when something happens that we don't
necessarily want to happen, what do we
say?
[Silence]
That's what's meant.
We are explain we we when we when
something happens that we are you know
unpleased with something that we don't
want to happen what do we say we are
taught by the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam to say
this is the decree of Allah and what he
has chosen to happen what he has willed
happened. What he wills he does. That's
what we're taught. How do we know
something is the decree of Allah? Only
if it happens. That's the only way. But
before something happens, we don't know
if it's the decree of Allah.
So we can fight for that thing not to
happen.
Yes, we push and we fight and we try and
we plan to make sure that unpleasant
thing does not occur. But once it
happens and comes into existence,
we know that this is something Allah
decreed. And at that point, we never go
back and say, "If only I did this, this
would have happened. I should have done
this. This would have happened." Who are
you to change Allah's will? What does
that mean?
What hand is going to reach into the
heavens and rewrite Allah's script?
no hand. Right? And this is why we are
taught by the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam.
He said,
he said, "Seek aid in Allah in what you
do and never give up and
seek out and search
and seek to fulfill and obtain that
which will benefit you." in this life or
the hereafter
and never say to something that afflicts
you, if only I had done such and such,
such and such would have occurred.
He said, "And rather say, this is the
decree of Allah, and what he has willed,
he has done. For indeed low if only in
this context not all if only but in this
context will only what open a door of
the acts of a shan the whispers of a
shan things regret and weakness and
melancholy and depression and giving up
this comes from a shaitan and if only I
had done this is what opens those doors
upon a person so we don't say that
because that serves us no purpose at
this junction. And so what does the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam teach
us? That once it comes into existence,
we concede to the decree of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. But before that,
no, we try our best cuz we don't know if
that's been decreed by Allah or not.
Which is one of the reputations of the
misunderstanding people have with
regards to Allah's decree.
For instance, people say, you know, if
Allah wanted me to pray, I would pray.
If Allah wanted me to be good, he would
decree that I'm good. How do you know he
hasn't decreed for you to be good in the
future? Have you seen that? Have you
looked into the future in the past?
Sure. But you can't use that as
measurement. You haven't looked at the
preserved tablet of Allah to see if he
decreed or did not decree. The only way
we know if Allah decreed a certain thing
is if it happened. That's the only way.
So we fight against these things. We
fight against things that are
unpleasant, unp that are painful, that
are unnecessary.
But once they come to pass, we don't
look and say, "I could have done such
and such." That is the belief system of
the disbeliever.
Because the disbeliever has a bloated
overestimation
of himself and his abilities.
that the disbelievers say about someone
who died if they would have listened to
me, if they would have stayed with me,
they would have they would be alive
today. Allah said, if that's true, then
why will you eventually die? If all we
have to do to avoid death is listen to
you, why are you subject to death?
The answer is no one changes Allah's
decree. But we don't know what it is
until it already happens. Now, so that
answers right. This is how we always
harmonize between prophecy and command.
The commandments of Allah and the
prophecies of Allah and his messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Any other
[Arabic recitation]
Yes. Okay.
for this session. so I have one
related question about it's about the
dealing with other fellow Muslims
brothers and sisters right. So I think
they have in the day of Cayama there
will be dealings with other Muslims if I
have or some person has taken the rights
of other Muslim he will come or she will
come and say give me my rights back.
Right? So in that in that in that light
let's say if you're living in this world
and we come from different culture this
one basic example right and I'm inviting
some brother and he has some
expectations of you know giving some
good food or dealings and then somehow
he doesn't it or it is not up to
his standard or he their standard
[Arabic recitation]
hey you will say okay you didn't treat
me well on that day you invited me I am
expecting according to my culture such
and such things but I'm I was not
treated well I got hurt so that's one
example another example between any
two brothers there's some dealing happen
say you told me I got hurt it was really
bad and they don't talk to you know each
they don't talk each other until the day
of they die right so they essentially
they didn't reconcile so that's another
example will this be considered as you
the rights that was not satisfied and
that can be you know asked at the day of
in that light
[Arabic recitation]
of Allah on the day of judgment there's
two types of judgment that will happen
between people on the day of
resurrection
the first judgment is in physical rights
the second judgment is after that after
passing theat
at the gates of paradise. We'll speak
about both of them. So the first one is
the rights which are the physical
rights. What is oppression
in the Arabic language? What does it
mean in the Arabic language? In the
Arabic language
of
which is translated as oppression but in
the Arabic language the linguistic
meaning of is to decrease something
to subtract from something. This is
called.
Now when I oppress another person,
I am taking from that which is not
rightfully mine to take or I am not
making them whole. This is what is
meant. Now this is something that has to
be what? Quantifiable.
It can't just be left to I felt that it
should have been this way. That's not
necessarily something that can be
quantified. Right? We're speaking about
money. We're speaking about property.
We're speaking about a person's blood, a
person's body, a person's health.
Something that can be quantified. A
person's honor, his reputation. Right?
Now, you gave an example of a person
comes to your home for instance, you
invite them as a guest. A guest has a
right on his host or no. What's the
answer? Yes. The guest has a right over
his host.
The guest has a right, a god-given right
over his host. However, what are the
what are the parameters of those
rights? The parameters are
that a person is treated with the
average of what that person
treats his own family, right? With
the average of what that host has to
offer with the average of what that host
has to offer. That is your
responsibility as a host. Would that be
up to the standards of your guest?
It it depends. depends on where your
guest comes from, what social status he
has, what you know what what class of
person he is. And that is to be taken
into consideration. If I invite a king
or a scholar, it's not inviting a
peasant. They're not the same. They are
not the same. However, me as a host,
what I have to offer
is what I'm expected to give my guest is
from the median of what I offer or
sustain my family with. That is what is
expected. If less than what that is
given to a guest and if a person does
not adequately honor his guest whether
it be for the duration of the guest or
or for the treatment of the guest. Yes,
you will be asked about that on the day
of judgment and a person could be judged
by Allah and they will have to repay
that person on the day of judgment. That
is why in Islamic law, a guest has a
right to to file a claim against a
host who mistreats him. And Allah
mentions guests in the Quran who were
mistreated by their hosts. Doesn't he?
You guys remember a story where guests
were not treated by their hosts? Madim,
correct? And Allah spoke about their
hosts in a in with dispraise.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
whoever believes in Allah in the last
day then he is to honor his guest. Okay.
that that is the first type of
judgment. And if it is a physical
quantifiable
right that is owed that is where the
person will pay that or receive that.
Now after that judgment is complete, we
will all then go to cross the sur which
is the bridge and it is a bridge over
the hellfire and it has many
descriptions in the sunnah and
people will cross based on their
righteousness and eagerness to to to
goodness and righteousness.
If people were quick to righteousness,
they will be quick on the and if they
were slow to righteousness, they will be
slow across this bridge. However, upon
crossing this bridge, there is another
junction where there will be a
reconciliate a reconciliatory
judgment between the Muslim.
This will be with regards to people's
emotions.
person you know is jealous of this
person or a person has some kind of
ill will towards his brother or a person
was hurt by another in in a way
that is not really quantifiable right
it's just a feeling that they have and
this was mentioned by Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala in
Allah said And Allah will give them to
drink a purifying drink
said there is a lake on the gates of
paradise that the people the Muslim will
be given to drink from that will purify
their hearts of all of this
all of this animosity
or any ill will towards one another.
Then and only then will people be
allowed to enter into paradise. Now so
with that we have completed our 30
minutes for this evening.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]